on va faire lentilles portrait chinois
vous connaissez le portrait chinois
voici le portrait chinois je vous dis si
c'était un fils était une fleur vous
étiez une fleur mais vous me dites je
serai à myosotis je serai une rose bon
lente et portrait chinois c'est autre
chose on ne bouge pas
c'est une rupture d'anévrisme rupture
d'anévrisme c'est rapide
une injure vanille qu'il comptait mort
qui tâche il a souvent pris au mot dit
des quatre serpents audible vous êtes
une maladie incurable de toute façon
vrai dans la griffe parce que ça met les
gens à plein un accident travail bien
sûr c'est donc une perversion par se
parler de soi même à la troisième
personne
ah oui comme alain delon de nanisme 2
n'a pas plu il ya des plombiers ou si
monsieur bah oui ils disent comme ça
comment il va et j'adore un vice par
l'alcool les femmes servent ensemble une
arme un pistolet ou un supplice
je parais 2.2 chinois mais le monopoly
ben ouais j'aurais répondu l'astrologie
moi mais ça je suis dit ça tous les
jours maintenant c'est celui un jour
c'est une routine
si vous étiez un dictateur je serai
metteur en scène vous étiez une torture
la torture jean pierre foucault merci
jacques dutronc penser explique
on cherche midi éditeur
bien